cette semaine vous avez vu que les
nouveaux mots qui servaient dans le
dictionnaire je sais pas si vous avez vu
il y a eu gênance babtou
Go ça veut dire femme je l'ai appris
brouteur
est-ce que quelqu'un
c'est quoi bah c'est ceux qui sont dans
les pays subsahariens et qui drague des
petits fronts des femmes en France pour
essayer de gratter de l'argent il broute
enfin elle s'appelle brouter en fait et
la femme qui tombe amoureuse à distance
qui envoie de l'argent pour envoyer un
billet qui ne voit jamais le mecs
les routesus
[Rires]
c'est des espèces de phishing
sentimentale en fait c'est des michto
version
routeur existait déjà dans le
dictionnaire ah bah non les moutons
aussi
utiliser
Jacquie et Michel
en même temps je vous rappelle que quand
même je regarde tout ce qui se disent
sur les réseaux sociaux et le petit
reproche qu'on peut nous faire de temps
en temps c'est que ça parle un petit peu
trop de temps du coup on a fait un petit
jeu un peu amusant on a pris chacun
votre date de naissance on lui dira pas
pour tout le monde et on a regardé les
mots qui sont sortis votre année de
naissance alors moi par exemple 74
et camping-car
ah là disquette et camping-car bon ça va
franchement rien de plus aussi Laurent
Fontaine oui bon donner ton année ou pas
62 yéyé et spacieux
Gargarine c'est marrant j'imagine
culture mais c'est pas une autre premier
déborder 91 ouais tu fais plus oh là là
[ __ ] et non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pardon pardon en plus il y a les enfants
devant la télé je m'excuse Déborah il y
a eu slam et manga
mais slam je n'envoie cela
mais Benoît 89 émission Benoît 89 il y a
eu pin's et trash j'ai cru comprendre
merci ne riez pas ça madame on est en
vacances
pas de vulgarité vous l'êtes déjà assez
physiquement j'oublie tout peut rien
avoir du tout je ne donne pas la date
non pas plus on va la
retrouvera Isabelle
alors attendez Isa Isa Isa non non alors
loin d'Isabelle
fluo 80
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
perruque
vous vous êtes arrivé merci beaucoup eux
c'est simple alors là on prévoit bien
les gens Pascal il y a pas de
Jean-Pascal ici
ça s'appelle la culture générale
mais c'est l'équivalent donc de je sais
pas c'est 6000 € ah merde nous on n'a
pas
connucteur DVD si quand même HS la VHS
t'as pas connu bah alors c'est venu tout
de suite
parce qu'on mettait des on enregistré
grâce au microscope et du coup il y
avait une étiquette on mettait ce qu'il
y avait sur la glace pour la retrouver
après évidemment moi j'enregistré des
films de boules je m'étais trompé on a
mis
[Rires]
droite et people droite
et je suis une pipe
sur le genre de droite l'argent est plus
folle c'est bien
Isabelle ah c'est quoi l'oreillettes
c'est possible
que j'aime les vieux hommes c'est pour
ça
le tableau je vais vous dire moi ce que
c'est non je donne pas ton je fais
jamais ça Isabelle
ne remettez pas Isabelle et beroc et Big
Bang et menhir menhir magnifique
c'est bien
vous êtes sûr que c'était pas gang bang
plutôt
ça va
être très aime bien la vie on va dire
non non non
pourquoi parce que j'étais pour rien
mais tu sais que Isabelle et je dis au
téléspectateur c'est la moyenne des
Français c'est une fois par semaine en
couple depuis plus de quelques années
donc deux fois par semaine c'est deux
fois la même des Français c'est
l'entraînement hein
bravo et qui est qui manque on a fait on
a fait tout le monde